foreign
for many of us and you are back at work
or at school and have many goals you
want to accomplish
this might be a time of motivation or
struggle you find yourself having
trouble doing your work exercising and
eating healthily so you blame yourself
for not having more willpower or for
procrastinating too much
according to Behavioral Science you can
stop worrying about your willpower and
quit calling yourself procrastinator to
stay motivated you need to change your
circumstances and Outlook not your
personality
behavioral scientist at the University
of Chicago I've been studying what it
takes to be successful in God Pursuits
for over 20 years as an academic a
parent and an immigrant I've also
struggled with motivation myself
let me offer a few interventions that
can increase your productivity at work
school and Beyond
when monitoring progress looking back is
often the way to move forward
for any goal you can look back at what
you have achieved as well as forwarded
what is still have to do when Ming janku
and I served people standing in a long
line for an amusement park right in
South Korea we found that when they
looked back and saw how far they'd come
they were more motivated to wait back at
the University of Chicago when
uncommitted students look back at the
materials that they have already covered
for a final exam their motivation to
keep studying increased
beware of long middles we call it the
middle problem
we are highly motivated at the beginning
we want to reach our goal and we want to
do it right over time our motivation
declines as we lose steam to the extent
our goal has a clear endpoint as in the
case of graduating with a diploma our
motivation will pick up again toward the
end
in one experiment we mature artillery
and I found that people literally cut
Corners in the middle of a project
we handed our participants a pair of
scissors and asked them to cut out
several identical shapes with many
corners they cut through more corners in
the middle of the task
the solution keep middle short a weekly
healthy eating goal is better than a
monthly eating healthy goal as it offers
fewer days to cheat on your diet
it's hard to learn from feedback
especially negative one
emotionally failures poses Diego
which you're not missing the information
feedback offers cognitively people also
struggle the information in negative
feedback is less directed the
information in positive feedback whereas
success points us to a winning strategy
for failure people need to infer what
not to do
to increase learning from negative
feedback try giving advice to others who
might be struggling with a similar
problem
Angela Duckworth and I found that when
students job Seekers and overweight
individuals gave others advice on how to
succeed in studying finding a job and
eating healthily they were more
motivated to follow through
support intrinsic motivation
you're intrinsically motivated when you
pursue an activity that feels like an
end in itself you do something for the
sake of doing it
if you wish you had a few more minutes
to finish your work by the end of the
day you're intrinsically motivated
if you can't wait to go home you aren't
to increase intrinsic motivation start
with selecting activities that you enjoy
pursuing a workout that you actually
enjoy is more likely to become part of
your routine
often people choose the wrong activity
in an experiment Caitlyn Wooley and I
ask people to choose between listening
to the song Hey Jude by the Beatles and
listening to a loud alarm
seems like an obvious choice right
but the majority of the people chose the
alarm because it paid more
later these people regretted their
choice
whether you look back cut the mill give
advice support intrinsic motivation keep
in mind
success does not require changing
yourself to stop procrastinate modify
your situation and Outlook
thank you so much that was wonderful and
I'd love to get into some of the the the
pieces that you suggested
um I think maybe one place to really
start is this idea of intrinsic
motivation so could you talk a little
bit about about intrinsic motivation
what is it and why is it so important
yes intrinsic motivation is a critical
for success
because intrinsic motivation is the the
things that we are getting from doing
the activity and activity is purely
intrinsically a motivating when it's an
end in itself okay when it doesn't even
make sense to ask why do I do it I do it
because I like doing it
well when we try to motivate ourselves
usually we have some goals that are not
purely intrinsically uh motivating they
like I I need to finish this project at
work or I need to to study for this
class but still there is some level of
intrinsic motivation it might be
interesting okay it might be fun okay uh
it might be energizing and the more I
feel like doing the thing isn't ending
itself the more motivated people are
going to be
now let me also add that this is uh not
intuitive for people I mentioned that
when we ask people to choose between two
activities they they went for the
activity that that paid more and not for
the one that were they were more likely
to enjoy and actually stick at that job
later we see that there are two
mispredictions people think that other
people don't care about enjoying
motivation as much as they do and they
think that they themselves will not care
about enjoying motivation as much as
they end up caring
that can explain a lot of the
professional choices that we make that
are not ideal that no choosing the wrong
workout regimen uh the the wrong healthy
diet for ourselves because we we don't
quite appreciate how important it is to
choose something that is not only a
means to an end but also feels like the
end by itself
um and I you know since we're talking
about some of the things you shared in
the talk I'd love to also go back to
another piece you mentioned there which
is just about negative feedback and you
you said that it's it's uh it's hard for
people to to learn uh from negative
feedback so could you talk a little bit
more about about that and um and what
sort of feedback how we can lean more
into this the positive feedback as you
as you described
completely so let me first say that I
don't say that there is a not much
negative feedback there there is okay
there are important lessons in negative
feedback however it's hard to learn
those lessons okay and it's hard first
because emotionally negative feedback
feels bad okay so we did some gauge okay
we we tune out okay uh in one of the the
studies that uh we ran we found that
people don't remember the feedback and
don't even remember their answer when
it's negative okay they they just
disengage with the task they don't learn
the other reason that it's harder to
learn from negative feedback is is much
more cognitive
it's not what we expected to hear and so
you know if you did something expecting
something to happen and then it happened
like you kind of had a prediction that
was supported with what later happened
and you remember it when you get
negative feedback it's often not what
you expected and that can be a very
confusing experience for people and and
so they they just don't learn it just
cognitively are harder task to to learn
from what's not it's learning by
elimination so
negative feedback is is important they
are often unique lessons in negative
feedback not to mention that if we don't
learn from negative feedback we are
probably missing just a lot of the
information that is out there and so we
need to be able to do that and I
mentioned giving advice and like one of
the strategies that we can use to learn
from negative feedback we also need to
realize that it is so much easier to
learn from positive feedback so you know
whenever we can teach someone through
positive feedback there are probably
going to be more attentive and better
able to learn
and you talk about that in the way of
giving advice and that sort of puts you
in this space of thinking positively
towards someone and maybe potentially
receiving more positive feedback
yourself
yes and okay uh not only it puts you in
a position of power and doing something
useful for the feedback helping another
person it also forces you to think about
what you have learned
okay and and often now when we ask
people to give advice in particular
people that are struggling
their immediate response is like what do
I know okay why would you ask me I know
I'm unemployed well like not me but the
person we're asking I'm unemployed why
do you would you ask me about how to get
a job and you kind of need to remind
them well you know how to get a job
because you've been doing that that
because you've been struggling and that
forces the person to think about what
they have learned and so it kind of
tackling both the emotional barrier to
learning and the cognitive barrier to
learning we have a question here from
from Ted member Miriam um they ask how
do we find perseverance and grit for the
dreams and goals that take time so how
do we redefine the timelines and bring
that into our life
oh Miriam that's that's a real problem
right because um
because of the middle problem right
because we are excited when we start on
something we are excited when we are
about to achieve an important Milestone
or you know the ultimate goal and in the
middle we we lose team okay we lose our
motivation
and uh what I would say is break your
goal into a sub goals okay self saving
for retirement is you know my ultimate
example saving for retirement is
a really hard call because you you need
to start working on this goal when
you're so far from completing the goal
okay when it seems like it's going to be
a different person that I don't really
know that would benefit from from
pursuing this goal but you can think
about your annual savings okay now how
much did you save this year for
retirement no how much you're going to
save in total
exercising goal people talk about a
weekly exercising role now clearly you
do not just want to exercise this week
okay you will have that goal again next
week
well you set a weekly exercise goal so
it has a beginning and an end and very
short middle
school is an interesting one because it
is actually easier in higher education
where we we break the year more clearly
into terms which are relatively short so
there is not much of a middle
and for for kids they have their long
ear which is kind of hard okay like you
start in September so maybe you're
excited on the first week and then you
will be again excited in June when the
school year is about to end but it was
such a long middle
break it into a weekly goal a monthly
goal something that has a short middle
that is not long term people are not
good at pursuing something where the
benefits are very far so I mean in your
research have you found that people of
different backgrounds that you know by
age or gender or race that they
experience
um motivation differently or that there
are certain strategies that are more
helpful
uh there is a lot of research on
developmental effects you you brought up
and several other variables that just
get me thinking in like uh 10 different
directions right now so let me focus on
that uh the age there are some really
interesting developmental effects
self-control develops with age so the
ability to put aside something because
there is something more important that
you want to do that's something that
develops into your 20s and that suggests
that maybe there was another reason why
we should stop calling our teenagers
airport cross teenagers and blaming them
for lack of self-control they are still
developing it uh at a later age we see
that as people's resources are like
physical resources are at the on the
decline uh then there are new challenges
and I you know I briefly touched the
idea that you often need to find the
compromise between several goals and you
need to think about how you you pursue
several goals at the same time
in in research we often look at this in
terms of finding activities that we
refer to them as multifinal they achieve
more than one goal okay it's like you
know my example is a bring bringing
lunch from home to your office this is a
healthier and saves you a time
and and it's often better food at least
for me okay so you achieve several goals
at the same time
with all their age
often you need to give more thought into
how to choose activities that allow you
to interact with other people while also
getting you your daily exercise while
also maybe
enjoying the the fresh air outside just
bringing more to the same activity
because maybe just less resources
we also see that you need to drop some
calls in your life and you know we
always drop calls when they are no
longer useful for us so maybe you used
to a run and and at one point uh that
didn't feel right for your body or you
were unable to do it and you had to
switch to a different exercise and
people often have crisis when they don't
need to switch from one girl to another
but because need to be dropped
um well well Ted member Ron asks um a
question about progress
um they want to know what do you do if
you look back over the last week or
month and you're disappointed in the
progress you've made how do you move
forward from that feeling
what so you can choose where they are to
look back or to look forward to one
right they get any point here like it's
completely up to you okay you can look
at what you achieved you can look at
what is that uh still amazing and you
can kind of
try to see what's motivating for you if
you are disappointed with the progress
that you have made now you have the
choice how to frame your disappointment
is it lack of commitment or lack of
progress now let's think about it if
it's lack of progress then you know your
disappointment is healthy okay that
suggests that you you should do more
yeah you have not made progress so let's
just you know double the effort let's
work harder
if your interpretation is lack of
commitment
well that's not great because now you
assume that you did not make progress
because probably you cannot make
progress and will never make progress
and we can see how I add that kind of uh
thinking is is not very healthy
and so what we find in studies is that
when people frame
some setbacks as lack of progress that
increases motivation I did not exercise
yesterday I should definitely exercise
today when they think about this lack of
commitment this is where we see problem
okay I did not exercise yesterday
I might not have it in me maybe I will
never be able to be there the person
that I wanted to be
it's up to you the framing is in you
know something that you can choose
or some one member asks um you know
about procrastinating for fear of
failing um do you have any tips for
dealing with that
yes there is a summit or shown what we
call self-handicapping okay and
self-handed cupping is an interesting
phenomenon it's like that the student
that purposely did not sleep the night
before the exam so that if she doesn't
do well she can blame the circumstances
okay she can say well I I was too tired
I had to do well
and we see that that sometimes people do
that because they are afraid to to try
because they are afraid about what
failure might mean for uh who they are
I think that as a society we should
probably just have a healthier
relationships with that with setbacks
there is a lot of walking motivation
science about how to to learn from
failure how to learn from setback
probably the basic thing is to
understand that there are lessons in
there okay that was not uh a wasted
experience skate that that made me the
person that I am that enriched me as
somehow okay I think you know I think
about it if you try to cook something
and and you burn the dish well
you don't have dinner but you learn
something about cooking okay and think
about what you've learned yeah yeah
um well I mean we I'm sure we have a lot
of people on on who are part of teams or
you know working in groups and 10-member
comb um they ask about how you can
motivate and unstick and stick a group
of people a team uh they leave multiple
medium-sized teams and sometimes can
sense that they're feeling a lack of
motivation among among the team members
yeah well the larger the team the the
larger the problem with motivation
okay uh basically uh this is what we
call social loafing okay when there are
many people that can do the work uh then
no we all tend to to leave the work to
uh to someone else and we see these
effects really uh increasing very
rapidly with the size of the team so
there will be less social loafing and a
team of two people and uh much more when
it's it's a team of 10.
we know that since basically I have a
wingleman a French engineer when that
studies so when some studies with men
pulling a rope at the beginning of the
20th century okay as you can imagine
when several Men full erupt together
they invest less offered when they then
when they do it by themselves and and we
see it in studies no all the time
the simplest solution
make sure that you can identify people's
contributions okay that it's not
one pile of contribution okay we know
how much each person did we can say that
that Whitney like this is how much you
did and I yell at this is how much uh
you did we even see this with a donation
okay so you know sometimes you give
money to charity and it all goes into
some like large bucket and
your 10 contribution feels like a drop
in the ocean and other times some
organizations and charity campaigns they
make sure that they list each donation
so you can see that Whitney gave 10 and
this is much more motivating and likely
takes care of the problem with having a
large group of people working together
toward the goal
um
well I mean I think sort of in the same
bucket of thinking about positive and
negative ways to motivate in groups um
Ted member Han Solo asked from an
individual perspective about the
difference between positive and negative
motivation
um you know I want to do this versus I
need to do this to avoid trouble
um is there one that's better than the
other in terms of keeping a person
motivated I would say that yes do goals
are better than do not calls okay
approach goals are are better than an
avoidance goals
uh what do I mean by that when you
invite people to bring more positive
thoughts to their lives this is much
easier than when you tell them not to
think about something negative okay push
away negative thoughts when you are I
invite people to uh bring more healthy
foods to uh their their diet that's
easier than removing foods from their
their diet
do not cause
are problematic in particular when we
think about the long one when we think
about doing things more than today and
this week there are two reasons
one reason is that this approach this uh
to do a goals a
tend to just bring to mind what you need
to do where is that do not goals tend to
bring to mind what you should not do
okay so if you think that you should
like stop doing something or stop
thinking about something how do you know
if you're successful you ask yourself do
I still have this forbidding thought
well by asking you bring it to mind okay
the other reason is just reactants okay
when I tell you that you should not eat
something this is exactly the thing that
you want to eat okay like don't look to
the right well everybody's not looking
to the right right
let me also say that the one big
advantage of avoidance goals of do not
cause is that they seem urgent okay if I
tell you that you should stop each red
meat and it seems more urgent than that
and let's say it's a more green
vegetables and so avoidance girls have
their like place in our life they they
see me
urgent now the question was also about
like needs versus ones which
somewhat overlap with the approach
avoidance but uh not that not totally
there are things that we feel like we we
absolutely required to do okay that we
might feel that like you know a high
school degree is a guy like I need to do
it this is absolutely a mask where is a
higher education I want to do that like
that uh might be a extra bonus okay that
might be a wonderful thing
to do
and and then we find that uh there are
different emotions that are associated
with that these different goals so you
know where is a success on that on a
need okay successfully pursuing a need
is more likely to be associated with
feeling relieved and oh I did this
uh success only and I want golden and
aspiration is more likely to make us
proud they can make us feel that we
we've done more than we should have done
type member Joni was just curious about
sticking to a schedule and how important
that is to to reaching a goal and tips
for for doing that
yeah thanks for
the schedule
many people like to have a to-do list
okay and kind of going by the the to-do
list as it's just that the personal
anecdote that when I was debating the
the many covers for my book one of them
has a to-do list that was proposed by
the publisher and I said well like I
can't have a to-do list on the cover
because
I don't recommend to do this and I don't
write about a to-do list and so you you
kind of know how I feel about uh
sticking your your to-do list in a
schedule it's good to write down what
you want to do and I actually suggest
drawing your call system so your
different goals and the relationship
between them okay whether they help or a
suppress each other just that that you
understand your priorities
but then the idea about goals okay the
beauty about goals is that they get you
going okay they give you purpose they
make you intrinsically motivated they
make you engage you get to connect to
other people over goals you get to feel
good whether you have actually reached
all these goals on your to-do list often
who cares okay it doesn't really matter
okay it matters that you made progress
I'm not a fan of fast quickly I'm making
sure that you checked everything on the
list we're wrapping up your own accent
there's this one question sort of as a
follow-up from before which was just
about if if not to-do list what's sort
of an alternative to to that approach
a gold system okay now a goal system is
basically you writing down the main
goals that you currently wanted to
pursue okay so it doesn't need to be in
your entire life but in in this time in
in the year like what are the things
that are important for me and they could
be like in terms of like my social
relationship at work at the projects at
home what are the things that you want
to achieve okay and then what are the
activities that that serve any of these
goals and understand the relationship
between this goes between these
activities being particular on the look
for activities that help you achieve
several goals simultaneously these are
the things that you want to do
um and just as we're wrapping up here if
there's I guess one thing for for folks
to take away from this conversation what
do you feel like is the the big piece of
um advice that everyone should should
apply to their lives
uh you uh motivate yourself by uh
changing the situation and and the
framing of that and the situation it's
not about
um fantasizing that you will be a
different person it's it's really about
changing uh what's around you and and
how you see that okay how you find your
outlook of what's around you this is
basically the lesson by the way from the
social sciences okay so this is not just
for motivation this is how we we explain
people's behavior in terms of the the
situation that they are responding to
and it's very applicable to stay
motivated thank you so much yellet for
joining us today thanks everyone for
having me thank you with me for all
these wonderful questions
[Music]
thank you